[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
une convergence européenne ce lundi à
bruxelles siège des institutions de l'ue
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espèrent les
manifestants du convoi de la liberté
après avoir rallié paris hier une partie
d'entre eux se dirigeait vers le nord de
la france capitale bell
[Musique]
dites par les autorités locales à leurs
doutes destockage
[Musique]
elle est échanges diplomatiques se
poursuivent sur le dossier craignant la
recherche d'une désescalade le président
de l'ukraine a parlé à parler à son
homologue américain volodymyr zelensky
qui appelle au calme et à ne pas céder à
la panique hier c'est avec 21 meetings
que joe biden s'est entretenu il pointe
du doigt la posture américaine et
dénonce une situation mené à l'absurde
ces dernières années
[Musique]
une délégation de talibans à doha pour
réclamer une aide financière elle doit
s'entretenir ce lundi avec des
diplomates européens et du golfe alors
que l'embellie ce temps s'enlise dans
une profonde crise humanitaire depuis
l'arrêt de l'aide internationale
ce vendredi le président américain a
signé un décret permettant de prendre le
contrôle des actifs de la banque
centrale afghane déposée aux états unis
aura été longtemps réservé la moitié de
ces quelques 7 milliards de dollars à
des familles
du 11 septembre
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
après une halte hier à paris marquée par
de vives tensions avec les forces de
l'ordre les manifestants du convoi de la
liberté ont pris la route vers bruxelles
certains sont déjà sur place à quelques
1300 véhicules selon la police ont fait
escale près de lille avant un grand
rassemblement prévu demandant la
capitale bruxelloise les autorités
locales craignent un blocage de la ville
elles ont interdit tout rassemblement
sur place on retrouve notre reporter
david khalifa c'est un périple qui sait
compte en centaines de kilomètres pour
ces convoyeurs de la liberté qui ont
repris la route depuis ville potes à ce
matin certains ont fait une halte à
lille l aéroport de lescun d'autres sont
arrivés directement ici à bruxelles pour
cette mobilisation qui devrait se tenir
demain une mobilisation interdite un par
le maire qui a annoncé qu'il ferait tout
pour éviter un blocage de la capitale
belge une convergence européenne est
prévue avec des convois allemands des
convois hollandais des convois mêmes
espagnols et surtout évidemment france
est un objectif
elle réclamé la fin des restrictions un
sanitaire pourquoi avoir choisi à
bruxelles et bien parce que c'est le
symbole de l'europe même puisque le
parlement ainsi trouve alors comme je
vous le disais un certain on fait des
alpes à lille et d'autres sont arrivés
directement ici à bruxelles un
dispositif de sécurité important été mis
en place un par les autorités locales on
a pu apercevoir des camions avec un
canon à eau notamment de nombreux
camions de gendarmes et policiers est
également on a pu apercevoir également
sur les panneaux de signalisation qu'il
fallait s'attendre à de fortes
perturbations demain pour la circulation
je vous propose d'écouter quelques-uns
des convoyeurs à liberté qu'on a pu
interroger ce matin sur le parking l2
ville pas plus déterminé que jamais je
vous le disais c'est quelqu'un même
assez remarquable c'est que dans le pays
des droits de l'homme la répression et
la plus sauvage 1 puisque depuis les
gilet jaune ne savons très bien que ce
gouvernement de macron n'hésitent pas à
tirer sur des gens désarmés pacifique et
s'ils nous allons à bruxelles et que
comme tout le monde sait
le président de l'europe nous nous
attendons à la même chose mais là pour
la liberté on est là pour nos enfants
pour nous pour nous mais pour nous nos
vieux pour aussi pouvoir d'achat qui est
en train de dégringoler depuis quelques
mois et ceci pour montrer notre
mécontentement du gouvernement que ce
soient français ou européens qui nous
mène une politique sanitaire désastreuse
donc voilà on n'est pas anti lax on est
content les mesures sanitaires et on va
dire la mise à côté d'une certaine
population qui refuse de se plier au
gouvernement et à l'idéologie sanitaires
tels ras-le-bol de tous les citoyens je
vous dis que cela soit français labège
c'est tout le monde en a vraiment ras le
bol et on n'est pas écouté et regardé
comment on ne répond on y répond par une
présence policière par des fourgons de
l'armée par des blindés alors que nous
on a envie avec nos voitures
personnelles on met de l'argent dans nos
voitures et on est reçu comme de la
merde les convoyeurs de la liberté ont
prévu d'arriver de façon morcelée 1 dans
la capitale belge pour ne pas attirer
l'attention c'était l'objectif principal
et malgré ça sur les aires d'autoroute
comme nous sommes arrivés en belgique on
a pu voir les policiers faire des
contrôles réguliers des voitures
françaises pour leur demander leurs
intentions plus que je rappelle que la
mobilisation est interdite ici même une
la mobilisation qui s'annonce d'ores et
déjà historique pour bruxelles inspiré
par l'initiative canadienne les
manifestants sont partis des quatre
coins de la france vendredi pour
protester entre autres contre les
mesures sanitaires premier objectif hier
donc rejoindre paris malgré
l'interdiction de la préfecture de
police certains d'entre eux sont
parvenus à entrer dans la capitale des
heurts ont éclaté avec les forces de
l'ordre mobilisées en nombre tout le
haut tout le week end au total hier la
police a procédé à 513 verbalisation 97
interpellations dont celle de jérôme
rodriguez l'une des figures du mouvement
des gilet jaune retour sur cette
mobilisation hier avec bilal poison ni
un homme inconscient entouré par les
secours et les rues adjacentes à la plus
belle avenue du monde recouverte d'un
nuage de gaz lacrymogène alors que la
police repousse les derniers
manifestants
des images qui témoignent d'une fin de
soirée sous tension et à la proche de la
présidentielle de tout ce que le
gouvernement espérait ne pas voir après
le rassemblement d'opposants au pass
vaccinale plus tôt dans la journée ils
étaient des milliers à s'être retrouvés
aux portes de paris avec un objectif
rejoindre les champs elysées afin
d'éviter un blocage de la capitale sept
mille deux cents policiers et gendarmes
ont été mobilisés
soutenu par plusieurs blindés pourtant
malgré cet important dispositif et
l'interdiction de manifester annoncée
par la préfecture de paris le convoi de
la liberté réussi en début d'après-midi
atteindre l'arc de triomphe
les mondiale la victoire c'est pas que
nous dire cccc globale contre les élites
et contre l'indifférence contre la
gauche toute la malveillance et c'est
des gens qui se soulèvent pour justement
montrer leur amour interne et à l'oral
mois antérieur et se battre encore
jusqu'au bout il ya eu quelque chose
d'extraordinaire sur la route je le dis
vraiment au clac sono partout où il est
passé par les nationales les gens nous
ont fait des signes on a même vu un
maire avec avec son écharpe de faire des
grands signes et où une ambiance de
folie et à tous les points de chute des
bénévoles qui étaient là avec des
victuailles et tout c'était vraiment
quelque chose assez extraordinaire afin
de disperser les manifestants et de
libérer les champs-elysées les forces de
l'ordre font usage de gaz lacrymogènes
en marge de la manifestation jérôme
rodriguez figure d gilet jaune et
soutient des convois anti mesures
sanitaires est interpellé pour avoir
organisé une manifestation interdite par
le préfet de police de paris un jour
moindre pièce ne sait jamais en fait le
revendiquer comme un organisateur convoi
de la liberté il a dit qu'il soutenait
en fait ce convoi de la liberté mais
rendez vous compte que j'étais par la
rue saint-honoré ils étaient trois
personnes dont elle n'est pas des poux
dans le mouvement en fait dépendre la
liberté ils étaient juste là pour laver
ce qui est complètement son noir
en début de soirée la situation reste
tendue et la police peine à évacuer les
manifestants de plus en plus nombreux
bilan 80 17 interpellations et plus de
500 verbalisation ce dimanche le convoi
va prendre la direction de bruxelles où
des convois de toute l'europe ont prévu
de se retrouver
et le mouvement trouve un écho aussi en
nouvelle zélande classé est presque une
semaine maintenant que des manifestants
opposés aux restrictions sanitaires
campent devant le parlement pas
découragés par le cyclone dovi qui a
entraîné ce dimanche glissement terrain
évacuation à travers le pays ils
demandent notamment la fin de la
vaccination requises pour les personnes
travaillant dans certains secteurs comme
la santé
nous avons quatre enfants nous avons
deux voitures à payer nous avons un prêt
immobilier
nous avons beaucoup d'animaux et lorsque
nous avons perdu notre emploi prise de
l'obligation vaccinale est née samedi
nous allons perdre notre maison
nous avons tous des problèmes de santé
sous-jacents qui explique pourquoi nous
ne voulons pas du vat santé
je suis désolé mais dire à quelqu'un que
vous pouvez mourir en ayant ce vaccin
mais perdre votre emploi je ne vois pas
en quoi c'est un choix
la générosité a été absolument
phénoménale et c'est ce qui a amené les
gens ici l'amour dans leur coeur à la
générosité ils veulent retrouver leur
j'ai assisté à quelques manifestations
dans ma vie mais je n'ai jamais ressenti
ça les gens veulent juste
trouver leur vie vraiment et les gens
sont tristes lorsqu'ils ont perdu des
membres de leur famille ils ont perdu
leur emploi ils ont perdu leur business
leur gagnepain c'est fou
et joe biden et volodymyr à zelensky au
convenu selon la maison blanche de
poursuivre diplomatie et dissuasion face
à moscou le président américain s'est
entretenu avec son homologue ukrainien
les etats unis qui répète ce dimanche
qu'une invasion russe de l'ukraine est
possible à tout moment voilà des
semaines que washington sonne l'alertent
malgré les démentis de moscou
les discussions se poursuivent elles se
sont accélérées ces tout derniers jours
dans un climat de vive tension hier
après manuel macro c'est avec joe biden
que vladimir poutine a échangé entretien
à l'issue duquel le conseiller
diplomatique du président russe a
dénoncé une hystérie américaine on
écoute
la conversation d'aujourd'hui s'est
tenue dans une ambiance où les
responsables officiels américains
attisait d'une manière sans précédent
l'hystérie sur la prétendue inévitable
invasion de l'ukraine par la russie tout
le monde est au courant de cela
d'ailleurs c'est en se référant à la
probabilité d'un scénario aussi
catastrophique que la partie américaine
a demandé d'organiser cette conversation
téléphonique entre les présidents
aujourd'hui même si elle aurait dû avoir
lieu au début de la semaine prochaine
précisément lundi le président biden
s'est même référer à l'expérience de ses
prédécesseurs qui pendant les années de
la guerre froide faisait tout leur
possible pour éviter une catastrophe
éviter un conflit grave entre nos pays
il a dit que nos deux grandes puissances
sont toujours en concurrence mais elles
doivent tout faire pour maintenir la
stabilité et la sécurité dans le monde
entier il a également souligné qu'il
était nécessaire de faire tout ce qui
est possible pour éviter le pire des
scénarios dans le contexte de la
situation actuelle autour de l'ukraine
et justement dans ce contexte de
tensions auprès de marathon diplomatique
quels sont les risques réels d'un
conflit armé quelle est la posture des
états unis le regarde karine bcgo l'ofco
professeur à l'université d'état de
moscou
si les états unis ont envie de gagner
cette guerre très concrètement et de
récupérer physiquement le territoire du
donbass ils n'ont pas envie de mener
cette guerre donc beaucoup va dépendre
aussi de l'attitude de la russie qui
jusqu'à présent en tout cas aujourd'hui
a parfaitement tenu l'espèce d'assaut
diplomatique qui a été menée par les
chancelleries occidentales
et
semble résister et plus sa position sera
forte et plus il y aura des chances que
ce conflit armé n'est pas lieu au
conflit qui sévit dans le donbass à
l'est de l'ukraine séparatistes et
gouvernement de kiev s'opposent les
combats ont laissé des séquelles
reportage antoine frérot
comme vous pouvez le voir cette église
derrière moi a été durement touché lors
des combats c'était en 2014 même début
2015 en effet l'aéroport se trouve à
seulement quelques kilomètres d'ici
l'aéroport qui a été le sujet d'une
grande bataille est derrière moi la
nouvelle église qui a été construite
depuis peu mais qui a déjà été la cible
de tirs j'ai acheté le stanc de temps
sanguin gauche les embaucher ici en 2014
2015 en tous lieux d'importants combats
voilà pourquoi cette église est ce
monastère sont restés ainsi ils ont
brûlé vous voyez combien de fois ils ont
été touchés sur les murs on peut
imaginer ce qui s'est passé ici si on se
promène dans le cimetière on voit des
pierres tombales détruites beaucoup de
choses ont été brisées cet endroit est
unique parce que d'un côté il y à une
guerre en cours et dans le même temps
personne n'a baissé les bras la vie
continue et la spiritualité qui est
signé chez les peuples slaves rené si
proche des miens en eau et sur george
bush même si la religion et l'accès aux
lieux de culte sont importants pour la
population du dombass l'emploi est une
préoccupation majeure avec 850 employés
cette usine de fabrication de
réfrigérateurs a le mérite de n'avoir
jamais stoppé son activité même au plus
fort du conflit en 2014 et même si elle
ne tourne qu'à 30% de sa capacité
la direction veut croire à des
lendemains meilleurs
les perspectives c'est l'ouverture de
nouveaux marchés de vente ce qui
permettrait d'utiliser 100 % des
capacités de production d' employer
davantage de personnel et produire 2000
réfrigérateur par jour
le donbass qui était à l'époque le coeur
industriel de l'urss tente aussi de
remettre en ordre de marche son
industrie lourde c'est le cas du haut
fourneau de cette usine métallurgique
qui emploie pas moins de 4500 personnes
votre vote dans mon usine fonctionne
depuis longtemps mais après une pause de
deux ans elle a repris son activité le
20 avril 2021 l'année dernière nous
avons mis en service le haut fourneau
numéro un à présent le numéro deux est
prêt pour le lancement rapporte the
power of us minervois que ce soit en
reconstruisant des églises ou bien en
tentant de relancer l'activité
économique le dombass tentent de tourner
la page et ainsi aller de l'avant mais
tout ceci reste bien fragile en raison
des vives tensions avec le voisin
ukrainien
la crise ukrainienne qui s'invite dans
la campagne présidentielle en france la
candidate les républicains valérie
pécresse elle tenait ce dimanche un
grand meeting à paris celle qui
déclarant vouloir porter un nouvel
espoir et vente une nouvelle france
s'est exprimé sur d'aussi internationale
alors que la russie demande des
garanties sur sa sécurité et la non
expansion de l'otan à l'est notamment en
ukraine elle s'est positionnée et je
vous propose de l'écouter
aux ukrainiens il faut parler avec
franchise et leur dire que l'adhésion à
l'otan n'est pas à l'ordre du jour nous
devons mettre sur pied nous
l'organisation pour la sécurité
européenne de l'atlantique à l'oural
l'union européenne en matière de
sécurité doit prendre son destin en main
questions internationales abordé aussi
dans la journée par le candidat de la
france insoumise jean luc mélenchon lui
qui devant quelques 8000 sympathisants
réunis à montpellier a fustigé les
inégalités sociales et les profiteurs de
crise fin de citation pour lui la france
doit se détacher de l'otan écoutez je
propose que la france ne soit plus le
wagon de l'otan mais qu'elle soit
autonome souveraine
vivre
et qu'elle propose
aux nations
une ligne stratégique que nous
appliquerons pour nous mêmes la france
sera un pays
non-alignés ni avec les a ni avec les
autres souveraine libre
la candidate socialiste anne hidalgo et
elle en visite ozon qui avons la
martinique elle a fait halte en
guadeloupe où elle s'est rendue au chu
de pointe à pitre parmi ses promesses
électorales la prise en charge intégrale
des frais médicaux liés au chlordécone
les détails avec cyrielle bruit
[Musique]
opération séduction pour anne hidalgo en
pleine campagne la candidate ps à la
présidentielle cherche à conquérir
l'électorat de l'outre-mer un challenge
de taille pour la maire de paris à la
traîne dans les sondages qui doit au
plus vite redorer le blason des
socialistes alors que la gauche est plus
que jamais morcelé c'est un plaisir pour
moi de revenir c'est une terre que
j'aime dans laquelle je suis venu en
vacances mais aussi en tant que maire de
paris où nous avons tissé beaucoup de
liens avec la guadeloupe 1ère étape
choisie par la candidate le chu de
pointe à pitre cet établissement
hospitalier vétustes subit actuellement
la cinquième vague de kovy de 19 de
plein fouet anne hidalgo a décidé de
montrer son soutien aux personnels
soignants affaibli face à la crise
sanitaire
l'occasion pour elle de pointer du doigt
les décisions du gouvernement actuel
anne hidalgo souhaite en finir avec ce
qu'elle appelle la logique
hôpital-entreprise l'hôpital public
c'est un bien commun voilà c'est pas du
luxe personne ici ne demandent des
choses qui relèvent du luxe les gens ici
demande ce qui relève du besoin pour
soigner correctement bien dignement et
pour pouvoir travailler bien parmi ses
objectifs annoncés en vue de la
présidentielle le recrutement de 15
mille médecins par an ainsi que 25 mille
infirmières une visite aux antilles
placée également sous le signe de
l'écologie pour la candidate en visite
dans une exploitation
agroécologiques anne hidalgo est revenu
sur la gestion du scandale du
chlordécone elle pause une prise en
charge intégrale des frais médicaux lié
à l'empoisonnement par ce pesticide une
thématique qui parle aux habitants
puisque selon santé publique france plus
de 90% de la population adulte de
guadeloupe et de martinique est
contaminée par le chlordécone la
martinique ou la candidat de finir
ajustements sa tournée dans les antilles
avant de s'envoler pour la métropole et
lundi soir
est la santé qui prend une part plus ou
moins importante dans les programmes des
candidats à les parents d'enfants
atteints de cancers en appel à un fils
ont manifesté aujourd'hui devant le
ministère de la santé pour réclamer des
actions fortes de la part des autorités
publiques mobilisation à quelques jours
de la journée internationale des cancers
pédiatriques
chaque année 500 d'enfants meurent de
cette maladie en france manifestation
qui a suivi notre reporter sérielle
benavides bullion
les manifestants juste derrière moi qui
enchaîne les prises de parole depuis 14h
son médecin scientifique présidents
d'associations parents d'enfants malades
ou encore simple soutien ils sont venus
aujourd'hui des quatre coins de la
france pour porter haut et fort leur
lutte contre les cancers pédiatriques
cette initiative de marie thibeault elle
est la fondatrice de l'association stop
au cancer de nos enfants est elle même
maman d'un enfant malade je vous propose
de l'écouter c'est c'est l'hécatombe
c'est un tsunami c'est seul canton nous
déclare le cancer de son enfant on nous
met face à la mort de notre enfant fait
et donc chaque jour on avance en
espérant que le nôtre fera pas partie
des 500 enfants qui décèdent chaque
année du cancer et puis après on se bat
on rentre dans le combat parce que nos
enfants il n'a jamais jamais jamais
jamais
jamais une seule seconde il n'arrête et
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir un petit
garçon qui va bien aujourd'hui qui est
rentré en phase de guérison donc les
cinq ans ont passé je sais par où il est
passé je sais qu'il est passé à ça il
restait aussi je sais ici derrière moi
toutes les familles qui ont perdu leurs
enfants
et ça y'a rien de normal dans tout ça
est une de ce combat là je vois pas
comment c'est pas possible pas en faire
une force en fait des cancers qui
touchent chaque année 2000 cinq cents
enfants et en tue entre 400 et 500 et
pour lesquels la recherche n'est pas
encore assez poussée avec un manque
d'essais cliniques des causes de
maladies inexpliquée par les autorités
sanitaires des traitements peu adapté
avec parfois de très lourdes séquelles
et en temps de campagne présidentielle
certains candidats ont déjà pris parti
droits à congés en cas de règles
douloureuses ou pour les parents
d'enfants atteints par un cancer tva à
2,1 pour cent pour les produits
d'hygiène féminine la santé des femmes
les cancers pédiatriques et la santé
mentale seront les trois grandes causes
de mon quinquennat je refuse que des
enfants soient malades et meurent parce
qu'on ne les a pas protégés aujourd'hui
je vais à la rochelle dans un village où
il ya un nombre important de cancers
pédiatriques
nous ferons de la santé environnementale
une priorité
pour rappel une rallonge de 20 millions
d'euros a été voté en octobre dernier à
l'assemblée nationale pour la recherche
contre les cancers pédiatriques et
demain ce sera sandrine jaussaud débuté
modem de loire-atlantique qui organisera
un colloque à l'assemblée pour faire le
point sur ce budget à la veille de la
journée internationale des cancers de
l'enfant
c'est direction maintenant l'afghanistan
qui depuis la prise de pouvoir des
talibans on s'enfonce dans une crise
humanitaire selon l'onu plus de la
moitié de la population est menacée de
famine est l'aide internationale est à
l'arrêt elle représentait 75 % du budget
afghan une délégation de talibans et à
doha au qatar pour réclamer une aide
financière au moment où washington
s'apprête à prendre le contrôle des
actifs de la banque centrale afghane
déposée aux états unis explication
françois chisserez fitch
les etats-unis ont volé l'argent des
afghans 17 pancartes tenues par un
manifestants réunis devant la grande
mosquée id kah de kaboul une dizaine de
personnes appellent à protester contre
les états unis
[Musique]
ces manifestations vont s'étendre à tout
le pays dans chaque province et je
demande à tous les afghans de venir de
protester et de faire valoir leurs
droits
en cause la signature ce vendredi par
joe biden d'un décret lui permettant de
prendre la main sur les 7 milliards de
dollars d'actifs de la banque centrale
d'afghanistan déposées aux etats unis
ils manoeuvrent peu habituelle permise
grâce au pouvoir économique
extraordinaire que lui confère une loi
datant de 1977 prendre possession des
actifs d'un autre état une décision
controversée alors que l'afghanistan
traverse une grave crise humanitaire
depuis le retour au pouvoir les talibans
ont plusieurs fois réclamé en vain de
prendre contrôle des réserves de la
banque centrale afghane afin de relancer
l'économie du pays d avoir gelé en août
dernier par washington
certains pays comme la russie ou encore
le secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres s ont exhorté les états unis
allaient débloquer dans un communiqué
les responsables de la maison blanche
ont assuré que ces réserves de la banque
centrale afghane provenaient de
l'assistance continue et significative
des états unis et d'autres donateurs
internationaux pendant deux décennies et
précise que la moitié des 7 milliards de
dollars sera réservé à l'aide
humanitaire pour le peuple afghan il
s'agit d'un pas en avant dans l'effort
des états unis pour autoriser le
transfert d'une partie importante des
fonds pour répondre aux besoins du
peuple afghan le décret est conçu pour
permettre au fonds de parvenir au peuple
afghan tout en évitant qu'ils ne tombent
entre les mains des talibans et d'autres
acteurs malveillants l'autre moitié de
la somme sera elle réservée pour des
demandes d'indemnisation déposées par
des familles de victimes des attentats
du 11 septembre 2001 et qui réclame la
saisie des avoirs afghan del annonce un
des porte parole des talibans a critiqué
la décision américaine
le volet la prise de contrôle de
l'argent gelé qui appartient au peuple
afghan par les états unis montre le plus
bas niveau de déclare humain et moral
d'un pays et d'une nation
selon les nations unies 23 millions
d'afghans sont menacés directement par
la famille soit 55% de la population
40 aux djihadistes tués par l'armée
française au burkina faso après les
attentats au bénin voisin ces trois
attaques récentes à la bombe artisanale
avait fait neuf morts dont un ancien
militaire français dans un communiqué
l'état-major annonce l'engagement des
capacités aériennes de renseignements
pour localiser le groupe armé
responsable
les frappes aériennes ont eu lieu jeudi
quarante jihadistes ont donc trouvé la
mort l'analyse la dette d'elle crime
yacoub koundougou me chercheur associé
au groupe afrique de l'est pse
c'est la confirmation de la colt que le
djihadisme puisse contaminer de les gens
du golfe de guinée cette configuration
un
ami ni la france à y agir parce que si
la france ne réagit pas la france
perdrait totalement sa crédibilité et sa
légitimité sa présence dans cette région
qui est justifié listons par la lutte
contre ce fléau aujourd'hui cette
création rapide de barkan qu'une
confirmation aussi de l'intention de la
france de marquer peut-être son probable
départ de marie que la france continuera
à combattre le terrorisme dans les
autres pays du champ et de la france
restera en scooter l'iniquité l'a pas le
seul et continuer le combat et c'est la
fin de cette édition se retrouve à
l'entraîneur pour un nouveau journal à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi il s'est tourné
vers le communisme il pensait que la
gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne donc il regardait
l'union soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
vous
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde